Detective fiction always turns on it's
revelations on those moments when
information suddenly transforms into
cause and effect,
no one is better at achieving those
revelations.
Then private detective Sherlock Holmes,
and these days no one is better at
visualizing them.
Then the creators of Sherlock,
the intoxicatingly inventive TV show
that uses and imagines film editing as a
function of its main character's mind.
You said your life turned on one word.
Yes.
The name of the person the father wanted
to kill.
Today I want to look at how sherlock
gets from point a to point b from
problem to solution,
mystery to clarity,
and one of the shows most extraordinary
visual revelations.
It's a sequence that lasts three minutes
and 42 seconds with a fresh,
weird idea and almost every beat.
It's a complete joy to watch unfold.
You said your life turned on one word.
Yes.
The name of the person the father wanted
to kill
the background is this,
the daughter of famous multimillionaire
Culverton Smith knows her father wants
to kill someone but doesn't know who it
is.
I need to kill someone and she was told
the name once,
but under the influence of a drug that
wiped her memory.
All she knows is that it's one word
that's the impossible thing.
Just that right there.
Some possible names are one word that
always at least two.
The added element here at one that's
going to spin this revelation into a
whole nother gear is that Sherlock
Holmes is on drugs.
He's been shooting cocaine,
a reference to the original Conan doyle
stories,
and it's accelerating and twisting his
mind.
In fact,
it's a pain of withdrawal from these
drugs that puts the entire sequence in
motion.
You know what?
I expect it.
What am I nicer
in a mystery,
a revelation on the part of the
detective or the audience only works
when it arises from information already
known.
What's new is the perspective,
and that change in perspective is
triggered usually by something that
doesn't mean to.
I mean this kind of revelation is a
cliche by now,
but what sherlock does differently is
stage those perspective shifts in its
camera work and editing.
In that first subsequence,
we see sherlock from every possible
angle,
even from one that's impossible thanks
to his drug induced state,
punctuated by subliminal negative shots
of the confession paper that faith was
holding and a compliment.
You know what?
I expect it nicer.
Anyone.
It's not just that sherlock
recontextualizes old information.
The filmmakers take great pains to
choreograph a relationship between old
and new perspectives that is
conversational,
like the present and the past are
speaking to each other.
In this part.
For example,
sherlock stalks the location of an old
episode,
the previous one,
but now everything is changed.
Instead of seeing the street from a
different angle,
we see it from a totally different
camera lens.
Adding to that sense of attenuated
drugged up disorientation and hear the
conversation with the past is even more
literal.
It's a present shot.
Past reverse shot is only one way that
I've been sold.
If you've already moved the camera and
you've already changed the Lens,
why not transplant an entire set from
earlier in the episode?
I need to kill something.
Hey,
anyone?
Anyone?
Anyone else?
Anyone.
Even more impressive than how Sherlock
arrives at his revelation is how the
hero untangles,
what that means,
and what can only be called a leapfrog
scene.
Transition.
Maybe my favorite of all time.
Sherlock awakes from his reverie.
It goes like this.
Sherlock realizes where he is in the
middle of a busy street,
a man yells at him,
reverse shot,
sherlock,
reverse shot.
That man is now his drug dealing friend
on the street reverse shot,
sherlock,
reverse shot.
His drug dealing friend is actually
speaking to him from Baker Street.
Reverse shot sherlock still outside,
reverse shot drug dealer telling him
that he's actually at Baker street to
reverse shot.
Cue the best location,
transition effort.
Now let's watch that in real time.
What are you doing?
What were you doing in the middle of a
bloody street?
Baker Street.
So will you.
It's
hard to imagine a scenario where more
could be accomplished with 10 shots and
sherlock's mind catches up with itself
and he grapples with the thought of just
how many serial killers might be hiding
behind wealth and fame like Culverton
Smith,
the revelation,
the drugs and the sequence reach their
crescendo with the set itself turning on
its axis.
It's important I think to remember that
what we've seen here has taken place in
the span of only three minutes and 42
seconds.
I mean there are full movies with fewer
original ideas.
There is no CGI in the sequence,
no digital fireworks.
This is just filmmaking,
just the laws of editing embodied
brilliantly as the workings of an
extraordinary mind.
So the nerdwriter crossed a million
subscribers last week and that is the
biggest professional milestone in my
life.
In 2017,
I want to make a show that lives up to
the amount of people who are watching
it.
I hope.
When you tell people about the show,
you say it something that you've never
seen on youtube or TV or anywhere.
That's the vision I have in my head and
that's what I'm always thinking about
when I'm making new episodes,
so thank you for watching.
Thank you for getting me to this place.
I don't take it lightly.
Like I said before,
thank you to squarespace for sponsoring
this video.
If you don't know,
squarespace has beautiful award winning
designer templates for websites for your
business or brand.
If you're a musician or you're starting
a restaurant or anything,
it's a perfect all in one platform.
Um,
that has great customer service.
Twenty four hours a day.
It's got easy domain names,
it's flexible,
it's just a great service.
If you want to build a website for your
business.
And,
uh,
if you start a free trial today using
the offer code nerdwriter,
you can get 10 percent off your first
purchase.
That's pretty cool.
Thank you guys for watching.
And I'll see everybody next Wednesday.